all right who here watches shark tank do
you like that show shark tank I love
that show I love that show it's on
tonight and if you haven't seen it it's
where inventors pitch their products to
investors and a few weeks ago they asked
me to be a guest shark and here's what
happened next into the tank is Roger
Sullivan with an eye-opening new product
my name is Roger Sullivan my company is
wired waffles basically we've taken an
energy drink and we put it into a waffle
think about it people walk into a
convenience store and they grab an
energy drink or a shot for their energy
but they still need a snack to satisfy
their hunger the wired waffle does both
I brought some samples for you guys to
try sir there you go
so who wants to shake on a deal and make
some money along these last in my car it
lasts for 30 days on the shelf how much
caffeine is in this is this like making
5 cups it's about a 20 ounce premium cup
of coffee but it's really like four or
five cups of coffee isn't that right dr.
Greene it's about me so if I if I ate
two of these what would happen I'll tell
you what would happen is you'd be you'd
be excited it's what you'd be your big
toe fly you can fly right right huh you
just be excited like how you hearty if
you have one bite that's a lot of
caffeine and it's a sweet so kids are
gonna get their hands on it and I think
that's very problematic we have a best
waffles I've ever had I usually I cannot
believe the taste sensation that is
happening right now not only in my mouth
but in my entire body I feel like I can
taste things like like my fear excited
no man is good I just think it's a bit
of a life record final question I'm
thinking about giving you the money
because it gave us the energy I have a
question right each waffle how much is
each waffle to buy how much is it ten
pack or like a 20 pack for like a
hundred like having it how many how much
is a hundred of them about a thousand
dollars
I don't really know people to eat cold
waffles
I love Oh waffles there's my offer
absolutely 1 million dollars for two
hundred percent of your company
oh really
I didn't get him to take my offer but I
did bench press Mark Cuban eight times
oh that was fun we'll be right back